[Laughter]
y
[Music]
for
[Laughter]
in
[Music]
for
[Laughter]
[Music]
for
in
[Music]
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the dun the three Muslims today
alhamdulillah we finally they have the
three Muslims back Al together at the
same place at the same time and um feels
good alhamdulillah how you guys
doing
alhamdulillah can you guys hear me well
yeah yeah we can hear you okay
alhamdulillah just gonna put my mic in
bro no
inallah Marco says just subscribed at
the three Muslims Shan can't wait to
rock
aldah your brothers we love and need and
we pray for you and you pray for us
inshallah may Allah bless you immensely
and accept all of our Good Deeds
aan a mean can you guys hear me through
the mic now yes I think I think it's
good alhamdulillah okay un man we we
getting up close and personal with your
neck well I'm trying uh for some reason
when I when I put this link on in my
phone it's just it's coming out real
weird so I'm trying to set this up
nicely okay good inshah sounds good oh
we got top G in the house too
yeah how you been alhamdulillah good
been busy but it's a good problem to
have alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah you guys excited for this
reaction have you seen any clips from
this video or no yeah I've uh I've seen
a good good portion of it and I have my
opinions on it already
alhamdulillah he's going to send uh a
message on the the group chat just check
that out whenever you guys can
in how you
feel alhamdulillah I feel a lot better
than I did in in the Chicago that's for
sure alhamdulillah yeah I remember I
remember that you're were like half dead
alhamdulillah you guys will see those uh
the other podcast when it drops with
dril
in the three Muslims once you watch this
you'll be surprised how good of a chef
Andrew is
inshallah let him cook it's funny man
Pier is such a weird guy like he's just
he literally he flipflops so much and I
don't know if it depends on who he's
talking to or depends on like who he
spoke to last but it's uh it's pretty
upsetting to be
honest yeah I feel like he's
intentionally flip-floppy because it it
keeps that moral ambiguity no one knows
where he stands and it keeps the comment
section engaging keeps people wanting to
tune in more
yeah but I think the people are smart
enough to realize that smart enough to
be like you know he he he's very clear
in his cond condemnation of the food
humus but not in the U non-existent isra
uh I can't even say that word was real
was real food
yeah OG t3m family members will know
that anho is in the lab the OG where it
all started inshallah we cannot quite
see the ceiling fan right now in the
background
but there we go bro I'm getting
[Laughter]
Nostalgia
okay just before we start um aw says may
Allah strengthen your brothers and
Safeguard you against all evil and said
goodness your way and for you as bless
you all
right oh that's not supposed to be the
spotlight imagine me piers and anho are
reacting to me PL twist
Char one
day between Israel and Hamas in Gaza
what is your view of this War I think
when you call it a war you're doing a
disservice to the people who are having
their limbs blown off by some of the
most advanced technical Weaponry on the
planet it is a genocide and it is
disgusting and it doesn't matter which
side of the political Spectrum you fall
on When You observe a genocide in front
of your very eyes you should be
disgusting which side is waging genocide
the Israelis are genociding the
Palestinians and you know it as well as
everybody else do well then it seems
like your bosses are not allowing you to
know it what do you think of of what
Hamas did in October the 7th why are you
starting the story in the middle I just
asked you about the Wide War I'm now ask
I can't Prof I cannot professionally
answer that question without talking
about the context that led up to October
7th well nothing to my mind justifies
what happened in October the 7th nothing
justifies what happened before October
the 7th appears this the exact point so
you're talking to a man I don't know
what answer you expect from me cuz let's
forget the fact I'm a Muslim you're
talking to a man who is fighting
oppression to the best of his ability
because he believes that the people in
charge of the world are enslaving us all
to the point where I detriment my own
life I end up at a jail cell because I'm
speaking against oppression then you're
asking me what I would do if my family
was blown to Pieces you're not in a jail
hang you ask me what I would do if
another government came along and blew
my family to pieces you weren't put in a
jail cell because of Any oppression
absolutely I was no you weren't you were
put in jail cell because you been
accused of serious sexual I would not
have been accused if I was not
monumentally successful in speaking the
truth let me ask you again it's a simple
question some people can answer it
straight away including Pro Palestinians
people I've had on my program many are
very quick to say absolutely do you
believe Hamas are a terror organization
and that's a very interesting question
but I think you're pedaling Asin nities
we just answer the question can somebody
do me a favor Google Asin nities and
find out if it's a I know it means if
it's not make sure it's added to Webster
on top G's orders okay just me are they
a terror group you're pedaling as enties
because I'll tell tell you why Pierce
let me answer the question of course you
are a simple question that's like me
asking I tell you why I asked because
the UK where you were born prescribes
Hamas as a terror they also prescribe me
as dangerous to children in schools let
me explain
something if I were sit here and say is
stealing wrong and you'd say yes and I
go ah but what if the person stealing is
trying to feed their family and if they
don't their family are going to die is
it still wrong you're trying to take a
very and complicated argument and reduce
it down to one sentence which is failure
you're trying to equate dealing with a
mob of terrorists breaking over a border
going to Peaceful is that what isra did
a minute a mob of terrorist over and
killing people is that going through a
border on October the 7th oh October the
7th massacring young people okay I wna I
want to pause for a second and just jump
into it because there's a lot just to
unpack already it's funny because ENT
called him
out for just secluding the situation and
misrepresenting it intentionally and
then Pier said no I'm not and then did
the same exact thing who on Earth with
any ounce of knowledge on this topic is
going to refer to what what guys is and
its limitations as a border as a border
it's a fence it's a blockade it's
literally and I'm trying not to use any
demonetizing words here but it's an
illegal annexation it's an illegal
blockade that the UN in every single
human rights organization that's
reputable on the face of the Earth even
bet selum which is in Israel
I just said the word but regardless it's
in there they condemn it even the the
Supreme Court there excepts that it's an
illegal occupation they broke through a
concentration
CM so even him just saying they crossed
the border they jumped over the border
is completely illegitimate and how the
heck did they even do that to begin with
this is one of the most heavily
surveilled places on the face of the
Earth and These Guys these nomadic
people in a concentration CM just just
happened to break out 45 minutes of
breaking through the fence with a
bulldozer are you serious none of that
makes sense but of course Pi
doesn't engage in that he wants to Pedal
Asin nities as Andrew Tate said yeah
it's pathetic that he believes that the
UK or the West are in a position of any
moral High Ground so it's like the UK
has deemed you as this it's like okay
and what about it the UK might also
think alphabet education is good in
elementary school students that are what
age four
five yeah exactly like it's funny cuz
Pius himself he he opposed the irq war
and he keeps like preaching this to the
choir like to it's like it's like when a
racist person says oh I'm not racist I
have black friends this is like his
version for this topic I oppos the Iraq
War you know I I like Arab people just
as much as anyone else I I can call
things out when I think it's wrong he
went against the the government and what
they said the British government as well
they they didn't have a problem with it
they encouraged it America went and they
did it he was against it so why are the
sudden we quoting them as if there's
some kind of of authority Britain was
the Empire that started this whole mess
to begin with and we can summarize this
entire situation in one very simple
sentence they always talk about peace in
the Middle East let's make peace in the
Middle East why is there a war to begin
with the best way for America and
Britain and all these Western European
civilizations the best way for them to
make and keep peace in the Middle East
is to stay the hell out of it mhm what
the hell are they doing there in the
first place that's why when you hear
these things that Muhammad hijab said
like how can an occupier be in a
defensive position to begin with it's
absurd that people start the narrative
as in okay why did Hamas do what they
did in October 7th it's not about that
why are they why is Israel there in the
first place yeah and and even under
international law and this is so this is
how bankrupt the entire discussion is
for a lot of people under international
law according to special repertoire of
the UN the UN itself on multiple
resolutions the Palestinian
people are what's called what are
referred to as protected persons under
the Geneva Convention the Fourth Geneva
Convention when you say is that is I'm
just going to say the word that Israel
is an obliger occupant or occupier
pardon me of specifically they named
Gaza the West Bank including East
Jerusalem when you label them as obliger
occupant what you're saying is the
people in there are what you can refer
to as
protected persons one of the rights of
the protected persons under the fort
Geneva Convention is the right to Armed
resistance yes the right to Armed
struggle armed resistance and in the in
the I think early 80s or late 80s the
general assembly at the UN
urged Israel to stop all the the illegal
occupations to remove any settlements
and they also reaffirmed the right for
the Palestinian people to Armed
resistance
they have that right and as the occupier
legally itel doesn't have that right in
any way shape or
form according to International yeah on
I agree
[Laughter]
bro I'm trying not to speak as much
cuz I don't have headphones or mic or
anything like this so audio is Cris all
my yeah looks good sounds good
alhamdulillah yeah you want to chime in
before we resume
no no I have nothing to say right now
okay let's go back into
it now we reacting to me we go I don't
think they could see that massacring
families in their homes and a but
setting fire to them cutting their heads
off killing babies Oh killing babies
that was true well fine were the babies
vaccinated why you pause PA
pause we're not going to talk about the
vax obviously ly for many reasons but I
wanted yall to understand that this
video came out to the surface before the
mainstream media concluded from the idea
of themselves that Izzy was who started
October
7th you get what I mean it's pathetic
that him using this argument isn't even
an argument anymore because this video
came out like it was filmed before that
now the entire world knows as we' those
that I hope would have their eyes open
would have already known that Palestine
didn't start October 7th that I he did
but now that it's it's even there he
looks even more stupid that he used that
as an argument yeah and on top of that
like he it's this is a shameful level of
Journalism on the part of Piers Morgan
and an absolutely abysmally shameful
level of Journalism he knows very well
there has not been a shred when I say I
mean there has not been even a shred of
evidence of babies who were
like almost at all let alone with heads
off and all this stuff the allegations
of of graping non-existent or the sorry
not the not the allegation allegations
are there but the evidence of that to
prove that non-existent there has
recently been a haret investigation done
which is a uh I think a media company in
Israel where they concluded that one it
was most likely the case that hum didn't
even know about the Rave that was taking
place and secondly they
provided recording like a like actual
footage from an Israeli Apache which is
a gunned armed helicopter that's manned
by someone shooting right and in this
footage you could see them
indiscriminately shooting at in at
everyone including the the militants and
Israeli civilians so how many people
including the people we saw videos of
them charred and burnt in their car
were actually offed by the IDF by
Israeli militants and furthermore even
you know testimonies from weeks ago
within the first two weeks of the whole
thing starting you had Israeli civilians
who were taking hostage when they came
out they specifically said the IDF
killed my friends the IDF shot my
friends and this is not new like even
during 2008 2009 operation castled there
were only 10 Israeli
militants who passed away during that
six of them were killed by homeless you
want to know how the other four
died Friendly
Fire by their own people the idea of
shot the IDF four of them that's 40% of
the the militants who were shot that's
crazy and it's the same thing it's
called the Hannibal directive I know I'm
going on for a while they have this
protocol that they say they got rid of
but they didn't clearly where it's
basically shoot to kill everyone and
anything because you don't want them to
take hostages you don't want them to
have some kind of political upper hand
and uh basically a dead person Israeli
IDF anything is better than them being
taken
hostage it's been there for for decades
now this
directive so yeah again back to my main
point shameful level of Journalism on
the part of Piers Morgan absolutely
abysmal good conversation
anold just so you know I muted your mic
because there's like an echo from your
speakers you good bro I
understand definely it's inconvenience
right now okay no problem inshah let's
go back into
it find that funny no but the point I
making is that the media lies firstly
secondly I can ask you we can ask I can
ask you about different things at the
same time right so I'm asking you first
of all specifically what is your
reaction to what happened in October the
sure I'll answer the question
professionally I do not condone the loss
of human life on either side I think
anybody doing anything which directly
damages civilians is disgusting and
abhorent however I would be an amateur
if I could not sit and pretend I do not
understand the motivations behind either
side this is not even me taking a side I
understand why Israel is doing what is
doing I understand why Palestine is
doing what is doing however I still call
the Israeli actions absolutely abhorent
and genocidal okay we're going to come
to Israel's action I promise you we will
ask that question specifically but in
terms of what Hamas did on October the
7th do you accept that was an act of
terrorism it's an interesting question
because once not really it isight
because you're the person who would have
called Nelson Mandela a terrorist while
he was still in jail and one person's
terrorist is another person's Freedom
fire for me to answer the question yes
you would have for for me to answer the
question I have to be very professional
Pierce for me to sit on the outside in
Romania with no personal involvement in
Israel Palestine it's easy for me to say
yes it was was an act of Terror however
if I was in Gaza if I was in an open air
prison if my family had been annihilated
by bombs from the sky if everybody I
knew had suffered the loss of a loved
one if I had no chance of any kind of
Freedom or democracy or standard of life
would I believe it was an act of Terror
or would I believe it's an act of
resistance against oppression you have
to be very careful how you answer these
question what do you think I think I
understand what happens when you take
people and put them in such an inhumane
condition for anybody to sit and say
that you're going to take people and put
them in absolutely inhumane conditions
and give them no standard of life and
they're not allowed to ever fight back
or they are ter age with anyone who does
is an amateur I can agree with you that
the plight of the Palestinians for many
decades has been absolutely shame so
what did we think was going to happen
Pierce no nothing justifies what
happened October what are they supposed
to do I'm sorry just I don't want to
divert too much why does he keep going
back to the seventh nothing justifies
nothing justifies it what's justifying
the belligerent occupation what's
justifying that nothing so why did it
happen the chronology is there's an
illegal occupation and then there's a
right to Armed resistance when that
armed resistance happens we get mad
about it it's literally the right of the
people to fight back obviously there
were there were there were bounds that
were crossed because even under
international law taking hostages from
either side is not allowed targeting
civilians is not allowed if if they even
did by the way which still not
absolutely proven them as an
organization maybe a few people 100% And
even the one one of the
commanders of homeless he said that
there are some people who broke out who
weren't from they weren't really with us
they broke out and did their own thing
but regardless put that aside because
it's all speculative why do you keep
going back to the seventh okay nothing
justifies okay nothing justifies it okay
what about what Israel is doing right
now or what is he's doing right now
15,000 people let's just take the
numbers quickly I'm talking a lot so I'm
going to just make the screen bigger
let's just take the numbers 15,000
approximately innocent civilians who
have been offed including babies in
incubators children babies still in the
womb of their mother okay this is the
reality of what's happening right now
15,000 and only about 65 I'll be
generous and say 80 Hamas militants
killed 80 15,000 civilians 80 militants
let's flip the number let's say for the
sake of argument it was 15,000 militants
and only 80 civilians that sounds
justifiable that sounds okay that sounds
like you wiped out half of them and only
lost a few casualties and that's
understandable so if that's an immense
win when you flip it to the reality
again what is that it's an immense loss
it's an epic failure and as one of the
generals
himself of izy said we're not going for
precision we're going for Destruction
yeah it's disgusting was this the same
general who himself was off recently or
no I don't know I'm not sure okay cuz
that was the one that was off that
started the ceasefire
oh really yeah yeah
yeah that's that's that's that's
horrible nyaho is done like he he's like
I If they don't if they don't take him
up to the the the IC or the icj and try
him as as a war criminal at the very
least like in the eyes of his own people
he's done yeah
absolutely on what you think pretty
boy
thinking
that I can't say much right now and I'll
probably message you guys on uh the
group chat later and tell you
why okay but this is
uh you know speaking on the actual video
at hand and you know what Andrew T is
saying about everything the man's got a
point and he puts it very
eloquently you know like you can
understand both sides right like it's if
anyone is getting attacked whether
it's the people in Izzy or the people in
hza like it doesn't matter who you are
it doesn't matter what you stand for if
you're getting attacked you you're going
to feel some type of way it's not going
to be pretty it's not going to be uh
it's not going to be beautiful right
it's not going to be something that
anyone wants but then to say that oh one
side is right or one side is wrong it's
kind of difficult if you're not in the
situation yourself you know and then
when you are in the situation it changes
everything yeah 100% the only people who
say this is a complex issue are the
people who don't want to talk about
it or the people that lack knowledge
yeah or both you like you you will not
find someone who's educated on the
topic um who is is for the rights the
basic human rights of the people of
Gazza who will say it's a complex issue
isue it's too much it's a lot and then
just talk about October 7th because
that's
disingenuous immensely disingenuous and
like let's apply this to any other
situation in the world like let's say
there was a fight and I say oh he
punched me and I just keep talking about
how the fact the fact that he punched me
he punched me he punched me but I don't
mention the fact that you know I tackled
him to the ground and held him down for
10 minutes straight I I think that's
pretty big context to the situation
because now that the focus of it shifts
from me
being the victim to now he's the victim
and I'm the aggressor and that's what
people aim to do when they focus on
October 7th they're aiming to make Izzy
the victim and these dang Arabs the Big
T word which is by the way it's not
really even
definitively uh mentioned or or I should
say it is mentioned isn't defined
properly under international law to
begin with and you me check the group
chat bro whenever you can once you
actually look
into
the once you actually look into the the
the definitions of it then you'll see uh
why they can't Define it properly but
let's get back to the uh
video what are they supposed to do that
was an act of medieval barbaric
terrorism nothing justifies did they
suffer acts of mediev did they
suffer bar did they suffer acts of
medieval barbaric terrorism before that
date yes and it's unfortunately an eye
for an eye in this world I'm not
condoning I'm being a professional and
answering give me one example give me
one example of where Israel without any
provocation went into what no wait a
specific question went into Gaza and
massacred 1500 innocent people cutting
their heads off taping and boasting
about what they' done back to their
families in Israel kidnapping Holocaust
Survivors bringing them they wouldn't
have course done that in that Cas
kidnapping old grandmothers and bringing
them back to Israel kidnapping babies
kidnapping children when has Israel
actually gone in and done something of
the scale of October the
7th this is another felicious argument
this is another huge felicious argument
so he asked when when when has is he
ever done something to this extent yeah
this is are you blind from like the last
couple decades of History yeah and the
fact that even ask us to be honest it
shows he's either ignorant or he's he's
malicious insanely malicious so let's on
hold should I bring you back
up okay
okay yeah yeah so I'm going to head out
but I just want to say my salams to
everybody uh for for reasons that of
which I will not say but Allah knows
best so I will see you guys
soon
so where do I begin
he's either ignorant of the situation or
he's malicious the reason I say that is
because let's say for the sake of
argument Izzy offed five people a day
and falsely imprison five people a day
and they did this every day for a
year and by the end of that year it's a
lot of people off a lot of people in
prison falsely let's say wrongful
imprisonment just because they didn't do
it all within one day doesn't make it
any less of an an
atrocity and this hasn't been going on
for a year this has been going on for 75
years they've been doing this for 75
years just look up bet salum they're
based in Izzy they're based in there
look up what they report is happening in
the West Bank against innocent
Palestinian men women and
children they take women and children
don't read them any charge and throw
them in prison that is hostage taking
that is false and wrongful imprisonment
of protected persons under the law it's
a violation of international law they
have close to
10,000
10,000 people who have been imprisoned
wrongfully without even their charges
being read to them including women and
children so there the kidnapping you
have that secondly just today I saw a
video of one brother who has family in
the West
Bank where they they described his
family members crib to him that there
were children whose whose stomach was
basically blown out from behind from
from from from back because they got
shot by the
IDF a
kid you can look up Amnesty
International Human Rights Watch bet
salum or the UN and just look up Israel
that's all you have to do just be
unbiased about it just look look those
words up with the the name of the
country and you will see how many
atrocities they committed
in 2009 2000 end of 2008 beginning
they offed around 1,400 innocent
civilians
1,400 including a big portion which was
offed during a ceasefire which was
agreed upon by both humus and by izy
they agreed to AAS fire then continue to
bomb and killed hundreds of them
hundreds Amnesty International has a
report titled 22 days of death and
destruction and you could read
everything they did there and it's the
most egregious disgusting stuff 1,400
which is the number Israel reported for
their casualties on October the 7th so
appear you asked where's where's
evidence of them doing that I gave you
two the hostage taking and the offing
innocent people and then you just look
at what they're saying you have
ambassadors saying that even the
children brought this upon themselves
yeah you have the Prime Minister saying
that you know calling on the people of
amalec which in the Bible says to off
the men the women the children the
infants sheep cattle camels and
donies and not not even the animals are
spared from them how is this not clear
rhetoric of wanting to cleanse people on
the basis of
ethnicity it's getting very difficult to
give him the ignorance card or the lack
of knowledge because he's a journalist
he should know these things yep
absolutely 100 % and that's why it's so
shocking because he himself should hold
himself to a high standard when it comes
to evidence for things but when when
when Al hospital was was was blown up he
quickly jumped on the the CNN
investigation saying that it was from
humus and it was a faulty
rocket just because the size of the
crater in the ground like I've never
seen such an abor excuse to blame uh
someone who doesn't have the military
capacity to even cause so much
damage and then later the New York Times
and others did their own investigation
including with with weapon Specialists
they did their own investigation and
came to conclusion that it was actually
an Izzy rocket that hit that hospital
but now four weeks later no one's
talking about it because it's it's just
old news but it was proven why did he
not cover this why did talk about that
very sad very
sad get
back 14 they were bombing civilians you
know what Pierce let me tell you
something I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about what they would categorize
as retaliation for Rocket strikes and
there's an arguable Point okay sorry I
know I know I know I'm doing it again
but
listen
retaliation retaliation for strikes what
about the right of the Palestinian
people to retaliate against the illegal
occupation which is illegal under every
single human rights
organization the Israeli Supreme Court
accepts it UN General assemblies un
resolutions and international law as a
whole which is the basis for every
organization saying that's illegal
where's their right to resist against
that if you say they have the right but
they can't off innocent men women
children okay we say the same thing
about Izzy they have the right to defend
themselves and their people but in a way
where they don't ethnically cleans
15,000
people two down we see see how quick it
is you guys see how fast it happens two
down now there's only one left who's to
say I'm not next
Allah
but seriously and you notice how he's
he's very Sly he's like give me an
example and he starts giving the example
he's like no I'm not talking about this
why do you keep Shifting the goalpost
are they allowed to retaliate or not if
not then you can't Grant it to either
side if you can then you have to Grant
it to both
you have to be
principled very sad it's actually very
very
sad the problem is he doesn't stop
talking that's the issue for example I'm
vehemently against the expansion of the
settlements on the West Bank I think
there are legitimate questions about the
proportionality of Israel's response
here but in terms of what Hamas
perpetrated on October the 7th there is
no no no instance of Israel doing that
to the people of Gaza and you have to
accept that sorry let me go back I want
to hear that garbage again oh that's too
far
damn no no no
Israel boasting about what they done
back to their families in Israel
kidnapping Holocaust Survivors I would
love to go talk to Piers Morgan
genuinely at this point before I was now
I would love to talk to him genu I would
love to speak to him about this as long
as he's fair and actually lets me speak
I would love to they wouldn't have
course done that and that kidnapping old
Grand mothers and bringing them back to
Israel kidnapping babies kidnapping
children when has Israel actually gone
in and done something what I was waiting
for the grandma it's like literally like
SpongeBob bro yeah it's like forget
forget kidnapping them is is he
completely just annihilates them a
bullet gives them a bullet literally
like I don't know what the heck he's on
and I I wish I wish I don't know if I
don't know if it's cuz Andrew Tate
didn't know about like certain events
that he could quote with numbers and and
sources um or if it was because peers
just did not let him speak and cut him
off every second word that he he uttered
but I would love for a time to be quoted
to him and for him to be put on the spot
because this this is this is a complete
Injustice to truth and as a journalist
this is shameful why are you talking
more than the guest you ask the question
sh be quiet let him answer you don't
like his answer then you can rebuttal
afterwards it's it's shameful to be
honest of the scale of October the 7th
there's literally endless examples of
that give me one in 2014 they were
bombing civilian you know what Pierce
let me tell you something I'm talking
about I'm not talking about what they
would categorized as retaliation for
Rocket strikes and there's an arguable
Point as there is for example I'm
vehemently against the expansion of the
settlements on the West Bank I think
there are legitimate questions about the
proportionality of Israel's response
here so does do Palestinians have a
right to Armed resistance against the
occupation yes but in terms of what
Hamas perpetrated on October the 7th
there is no no no instance of Israel
doing that to the people of Gaza that's
you have to accept that pause pause
pause there's no way he just said that
yeah that's that's that's a filthy
lie this is literally comedic at this
point yeah I mean I went through
numerous examples recently actually I
wanted to open up the document itself
I'm not going to share on the screen I
think it's a little too much but 22 days
of death and destruction I'm just going
to go to like the first page of it
literally it's right in the beginning
I'm just going to give you one fact that
will show you how
absolutely absolutely
disgusting this government is I'm going
to read and I quote at 11:30 a.m. on the
27th of December 2008 without
warning Izzy forces began a devastating
bombing campaign on theza strip code
named Operation castled what time 11:30
a.m. in the morning when you have a
population that's so
condensed what United Nations um you
know Educators and and and and
departments have to do is they have to
have school shifts they'll have a
morning shift from 7:30 to 11:30 or 6:30
to 11:30 then they'll have an afternoon
shift where all the morning shift kids
are on their way home all the afternoon
shift kids are on their way to school
everyone's in the street you know when
the shift the first shift ends and the
second one begins guess what time
11:30 11:30 a.m. is when the morning
shift for school ends for the so the
kids are going home and the next shift
begins so the the kids are going to
school they chose that time yes they
chose that time back in
2008 to start this this
strike why on Earth would do they choose
11:30 why
this is the the type of government that
we're dealing with here that's just the
first
line there's much more I have
highlighted but I'm gonna leave it at
that I'm I'm gonna spare you guys the
the talk right
now that you're either deluded or you're
deliberately not wanting to say the
obvious which is that was an act of
terrorism because you're concerned about
upsetting people in Palestine is that is
that the case let me go back to my first
point when I said you're pedling acties
the reason I said that is because to
look at a situation no matter how
heinous and to ignore all of the context
and pretend that you do not understand
why said situation happened is nothing
justifies terrorism on that scale
nothing is as no it's not it's not about
justification let tell you why it's not
about justification it's about
understanding the realities of the world
let me tell you the reality of the world
Hamas came to power in 2005 hamas's
initial founding Charter made it clear
that they are for the eradication of
Israel and on October the seven they
prove what that means is they will kill
every Jew they can get their hands on
they are an existential threat this is
such a stupid argument like this is
absolutely moronic because they changed
their
Charter before October 7th they changed
the charter before October 7th so him
quoting the first one that's no longer
valid no longer valid or being applied
no longer applicable he's quoting the
first one saying oh October 7th is what
it means it's no longer applicable
peers
it's very pathetic to people in Israel
and to Jewish people and that is I'm
afraid the purest personification of a
terror group I also think by doing what
they did as they have done since 2005
they weren't representing innocent
Palestinian people in Gaza suffering
they knew yes but Hamas knew when they
did what they did that Israel would
respond the way they did wow that's such
a great argument it's that's you know it
you know what it sounds like it sounds
like my wife knew what I would do to if
she pissed me off she knew I was going
to hit her but she made me mad anyways
that's what it sounds like Pierce does
that justify Israel offing 15,000
innocent men women and children babies
in incubators babies in their mother's
hands babies in their father's hands
babies still in their mother's womb you
are a filthy filthy person if you really
believe that and you describing what
humus did on October 7th as the most
clear Act of Terror then what about what
Izzy did in response in the the last
month 15,000 civilians civilians and
only 65 militants that is disgusting
what what what what would you describe
what's happening in the West Bank where
they invade people's homes in the middle
of the night randomly randomly as
reported by the founder of breaking the
silence used to be an IDF militant and
everyone else who's broken the science
was also an IDF militant you can read
the numerous reports that are done read
what Amnesty International says about
what happens in the West Bank read what
bet salum again which is based in is
reports on what happens in the West Bank
just listen to the settlers themselves
in the West Bank the settlers I just saw
a video of of a settler in I don't think
this was in the West Bank was actually
in Izzy probably like in Tel Aviv or
something there was a Christian preacher
and the the the the Israeli guy said to
him The Godly thing for me to do is to
you he said that to him to a Christian
preacher or Christian a Christian preach
uh priest actually not just a preacher
an actual priest he said said it him and
it's all I put I think I reposted on my
Twitter if you want to go see it this is
the level of
Geno cidal intent that we have
here yeah it was like that that one
video that went viral yesterday from the
guy that was harassing the Hal guys food
truck uh owner the steart whatever he
used to be a part of the Department of
State in New York under Obama yeah at
the end of it he said that oh 4,000 uh
filistini babies were offed wasn't
enough or something like that yeah these
are the people that we have that are for
the west by the West working
representing the west and every single
line of projection from Pierce Morgan is
obviously apparent to all of us yeah but
I generally wonder if he's
delusional or it's
intentful I think I think I think it's
both I think he has to willfully delude
himself to be able to say such stupid
things uh I would love to ask Piers a
question
I would love to ask him the question of
if you're blaming humus for is is's
response which ended the lives of 15,000
innocent men women and children and you
basically say that that's okay and
that's Justified because there was an
attack against them and civilians died
as a result of an attack back would you
say the same for Osama B ladin would you
say that cuz he used the same exact
argument he used the same argument that
these people are these zionists are
using that well listen they voted for
them they elected them it's their tax
dollars that are paying for them or
whatever they're you know it's their
supplies that uh that that homos is
using so they're all liable and they're
all subject to whatever punishment is
coming their way that's exactly what bin
L said and is recently removed from the
daily mail letter to
America so would you justify that for
them or would do you not justify for
them and last question is why do you
make a differentiation why do you make a
distinction between a a target attack
against civilians and a targeted attack
against civilian objects where you know
there are civilians what's the
difference what is the
difference all the stuff by the way is
covered under international law I know
he doesn't know that but what's the
difference there is none in
international law there is no difference
really says sh if I don't forget about
tomorrow Palestinians would get killed
they knew that and they still did it so
my question for you is why can't you
which is my position I'm sorry do you
hear that they knew thousands of
Palestinians would get
killed by who by who be accurate about
your statements they knew 15,000
Palestinians would be offed in air
strikes by why is
he be specific in your
wording on this is very straightforward
what Hamas did was an act of Terror an
absolutely despicable Act of Terror and
should be called exactly what it
is I really think that this man has
obviously he's a puppet and there's
Puppet Masters that are funding him and
they specifically give him scripts that
he has to follow that's why I find it
there's no way this man's just ignorant
if he doesn't see that how absurd he
sounds I think it's more likely the case
that he's just he's he's just he wants
to go with the status quo here I think
he just wants to go with the status
quo I and that's that's me being nice
that's me being generous to him which
frankly he doesn't deserve but I'm
willing to be generous I'm willing to be
generous until I think until he's
pressed more on the topic and he's
willing to be interrogated on topic I
think until then I'll be a bit generous
with him but this entire talking point
of its very very very obviously a case
of Terror in this situation but when the
other side does literally the same thing
and has done the same thing for 75
years when the the IDF themselves
ex-military um uh ex ex-militants from
the IDF they specifically say we had a
job to put our foot on their neck and
make them feel like they can never
Revolt when you have the Palestinian
Authority working with the Israeli
government and there's still oppression
of the palestin people and they're being
kicked out of their homes to make room
for illegal settlers illegal settlements
in the West Bank how was not not not an
act of Terror an act of of of cleansing
people on the basis of ethnicity it's
very shameful terrorist group that is
why they were rightly prescribed that by
the UK and America and other countries
and to try and protect last thing on
what definition what is the definition
of of of of Terror that you're using
here Define it I think that's how I'd
answer his question if you were to ask
me like do you think there are I'd be
like okay I'd love to answer that for
you define what what that means and as
soon as he defines it he basically doing
himself a
disservice 10 then not makes you sound
like Jeremy Corbin I can't give a worse
insult to throw at you right so I don't
think agree but I also think there are
legitimate questions to come about the
way Israel's responded we can come to
that but I just want to ask you one more
time is what Hamas did on October the
7th an act of terrorism I think pet it
is pedling Asin enties for you to
pretend that enslaving you sound like
Jeremy Corbin no let me answer the
question 15 times he refused to answer
the question the question you're now
refusing you're now about three or four
if you are they a terror group or not
they're one team's freedom fighter and
they are deemed a terror what do you
think I think that if you lock people in
an open air prison and steal their land
they're going to retaliate so they're
not a terror group I think they're going
to retaliate they're not a terror group
one team's terrorist is now about a are
they a terror group and also another
thing I want to make clear to you only
Jeremy has done this done what refused
to answer the question I think that what
they are doing is seemly deemed an act
of Terror by the people that the terror
these weasy words they're not weasly of
course the Israelis think they're a
terror group and of course some of
course the Palestinians think they're
Freedom Fighters it's stupid that you're
asking the question most of the
Civilized world thinks they a terror
group Committed an act of terrorism it's
not difficult what they did was an act
of terrorism I think that most of the
Civilized World also will say the same
exact thing about the government of
Israel they'll do this they'll say the
same exact thing empis civilized yeah
yeah so I I don't know what's wrong with
this guy really if Israel continues to
to conduct acts of terrorism on the
Palestinian people they're going to do
nothing but streng the reaction I'm
going that's a different conversation
I'm about to have the same ex I get
there one more time is Hamas a terror
group who committed an act of terrorism
he's such a loser I'm sorry I'm
sorry it just pisses me off so much why
are you so fixated on hearing these
words it's so pathetic like I need to
hear you say it I I know you have it in
you I need to hear you say it shut up
shut the hell up Pierce why are you so
like every single guest you have on
you're so focused on hearing them say
hos is a terrorist organization why do
you need to hear it why don't you ask
what they think about both hum and I
both why only one why only one why don't
you ask the same kind of questions the
benj when you had them on or the Israeli
Ambassador when you had her on why don't
you ask the same kind of questions the
only time that Pro zionists get pushed
on his show is when he has a pro
Palestinian there to push them that's
the only time he will never do it
himself but this is how he treats the
the quotequote prop Palestinian gas by
heckling them and cutting them off and
repeating the same moronic question time
and time again you know that they can be
a group of Terror or a group who
committed an act of Terror while
simultaneously being Freedom Fighters
while simultaneously having the right to
an armed resistance against illegal
occupation you know they can have both
they could they could be deemed as both
and you don't have to basically justify
the occupation you don't have to justify
the occupation because they committed an
act of Terror and you don't have to say
the Act of Terror is okay because
there's an occupation you could be very
specific say they are Freedom Fighters
and they're allowed to have armed
resistance but they went too far
according to international law why do
they go that far and and I'm only
talking about the taking of hostages I
am not going to sit here and say that
they innoc they they they targeted
innocent civilians until I see evidence
of that and in a ma on a mass scale by
the way I've seen a few videos it's
unfortunate it's wrong and that's
condemnable 100% show me it happening on
a mass scale and I'll I'll condemn them
100% but when it comes to the hostage
taking why do they do that maybe it's
because there are 10,000 innocent
Palestinian men women and children who
are locked in Israeli cages right now
maybe that's why maybe because there
were there are Ethiopian Jews who the
women were injected with something that
would enable their ability or disable
their ability to get pregnant maybe
that's why maybe it's because this is a
is a terror apartheid regime who was
illegally occupying Palestinian land
maybe that's why they took hostages now
I'm not saying it's okay but I'm saying
that this is context that you need to
bring in because had that not been there
they were there wouldn't have been this
response right and and and it's not even
a matter of who did it worse or who has
bigger numbers but it's a matter of Tate
said it best in the in the interview he
said that if you have a pressure cooker
eventually it's going to blow up
bro yeah yeah 100% And even even Elon
Musk said something I think that was a
good point he's like for every member
that you you know of the that militant
group that you you off how many do you
create I don't know if this statistic is
is true I think it was reported by like
abua or someone like someone one of the
generals or the leaders of of humus he
said that 80% of their militants are
orphans but you know what's true like
that's crazy who's cre who's creting
those orphans yeah and and and that's
crazy enough but even if that isn't true
let's just say for the sake it's
probably is to be honest let's say for
the sake of argument it it
isn't 100% of them were in a
concentration camp 100% of them
were a a huge portion of them were born
into it raised in it they've never seen
anything outside of it when they broke
through those walls it was the first
time they broke out it was the first
time they've been on the outside in
their entire life in their entire 20 to
25 years of being alive
so these are the facts that we need to
focus on in light of having this
discussion air prison you're going to
have to retaliation no because I have to
there's people who are firstly first
things I want to say per you know mind
me saying I think it's spineless sure I
do that's fine you sound like Jeremy
Corbin well that that is an did you see
my interview with him no right 15 times
last week I asked him the same question
15 times he I'm sorry this comment's so
funny why is he holding sheets of paper
he only has one question
yeah God bless you
eventually when someone does that enough
times sorry what the most pinned comment
on the debate was literally like appear
has been at for one month with different
guests just to find the answer to that
one question do you I know it's so funny
man it's it's it's so it's pathetic you
know what they really think you don't
think they're a ter let me think they're
I just want to say this whole video is
35 minutes long are we really going to
watch the whole thing so that's why the
link that I sent you was only 28 minutes
I don't think this is the same link bro
this is the exact link that you sent me
W
yeah this is the exact link Subhan Allah
it's okay though maybe maybe you got the
maybe I I uploaded the wrong link to
drive then because what I did was I sped
It Up by 1.25x so it was around like 25
minutes uh but yeah you can SK through
bro some some like mainly towards the
end that's when it gets very interesting
okay I don't think I saw that so that
that would be good but let me let let me
see where we're at now I skip back four
if you are they a terror group on
civilized world thinks look at scenarios
and you understand why they happen how
unfortunate they are how unfortunate the
loss of human life is how civilians die
on both sides how Innocents are dying in
a chess game played by the elites on
both sides both sides you have innocent
people who didn't even vote for the
person making the decisions who are
ensuring their death signing their death
warrant it's unfortunate on both sides
but listen sir you would not Advocate
Russia doing any of the things to
Ukraine that Israel is doing to to to to
Palestine you would not see Russia has
been doing exactly that Russia has not
done a fraction of ukra that Israel is
Russia illegally invaded a sovereign
Democratic country and has committed a
barbaric Rampage trying to seize as much
of Ukraine as it can bombing maternity
this guy I I no there's no way there's
no way that he just said that with a
straight
face Israel for 75 years has invaded
doesn't have to be a Sovereign Nation
because once people are occupied they're
protected persons under international
law I don't know if you know that you
probably don't because you're uneducated
in this topic but regardless they have
done that belligerently for 75 years in
a barbaric manner forced evictions
completely offing people wrongful
imprisonment including of children
murder including of children bombs tanks
accurate and inaccurate
artillery which which is is is is good
and bad on both sides because if it's
inaccurate why are you firing inaccurate
um uh missiles and in in in pieces of of
Weaponry into densely populated places
not knowing exactly where it's going to
land and secondly when you use an
accurate one you still off innocent
civilians so it's
completely completely unjustifiable and
they've been doing this for 75
years like for for the longest time they
invaded and wrongfully uprooted the
people off others through others in
jail and when when one country does it
it's horrible it's wrong it's barbaric
when they do it for some reason it's
acceptable in your
eyes that's oh my God man it's filthy
honestly it's
filthy inocent women question don't even
try and have some kind of no no this is
genation of this I will a Hamas rocket a
tiny Hamas rocket that can make a
pothole in the road and then they get
hit back with cruise missiles let me ask
you a question Ukraine sent drone and it
hit the Kremlin a drone attack it did
nothing it damaged some some shingles if
if Russia decided to then respond with a
missile attack on a hospital and
annihilate 800 people do you think that
would be allowed exactly what it has
been would you advocate for that would
you support that re mate of marapole
which they level to the ground the
ukrainians did level the correct no the
Russian 2014 the Russian LEL Maro and
and my question to you is would you
Advocate those reactions let me ask you
another question this is a genu question
let me ask you question CU I want
understand your point actually my
interview with you yeah but but you
that's another thing I hate that he does
I don't know if it if it only bothers me
but he says no this is my interview of
you this is my show I don't listen I
don't what does that mean I have to just
sit here and do every single thing you
ask I'm my own person I'm a guest on
your show I could choose what I answer
what I don't answer you don't want to
finish the interview okay you don't have
to you could frankly screw off I do not
come on here to be interrogated that's
what every single person should should
say I feel I think Muhammad should have
said it I think andw should have said it
any single person who he said uses that
line on say listen this is not what I
signed up for I'm going to ask you
questions you don't want to answer don't
answer you ask me questions I don't want
to answer I'm not going to answer and if
you don't like that okay screw you
frankly like like I I don't know why he
thinks he has some kind of power because
it's his show talk about what you want
but don't don't have me just sit here
listening to you Heckle for for 20
minutes
straight I just want to understand your
point of view if if I believed or if
Israel believed that one of the people
in your house was a terrorist and
decided to destroy destroy your entire
house and kill your entire family would
you sit and say well maybe there was a
terrorist inside I accept that or would
you be enraged genuine question I don't
think you can take an individual
person's response well it's a bunch of
individual people in Gaza there people
individuals with thoughts and dreams and
aspirations which are being annihilated
15-year-old girls without legs cuz of
cruise missiles they are individual
people they're cattle to people right
and so with the people in Israel October
the and that's why it's so which my but
not heinous enough to reach your bar of
terrorism bar Terror he is such a
hypocrite is it is it heinous enough to
reach your bar of Terror yeah when Izzy
does it to the Palestinians he's such a
hypocrite understanding yeah and then
and by the way right after that he said
let's move on you are pathetic by not
saying it you've made your position
clear just shut up the same thing with
you same thing with you same thing with
you anyways let let me skip throughout
this I skipped the minutes we'll see
where this is at and her parents were
dead when you see her crying her eyes
out begging to die that is hell and I
don't think you should genuinely wish
hell on anyone Israel or Palestinian
either anyone I'm a humanist I don't
want anybody to die and when he was
wishing hell on an entire population he
did Express regret for the way he
phrased and he should because it's
disgusting I've not wished hell on the
Israelis I've not wished hell on the
Israeli State I don't want any Israeli
civilian to go through with that
15-year-old Palestinian girl's going
through not by the way the only reason
Jordan Peterson said express any kind of
regret is not because of of what
unfolded afterwards to the Palestinian
people it's because he said he had a big
Muslim audience before and now they're
basically upset with him that's why he
regrets it he's like it's very pathetic
very very pathetic single one he said
about you Jordan Peterson I'm not
particularly happy to be grouped with
Andrew Tate I think there are some
elements about what he does that are
quite
reprehensible I'm sure he has I'm not I
don't know everything he says and he may
disagree with some of my points of view
as I said I have nothing against him I
don't think anything he says is
particularly wrong I think that he's
hypocritical because of the
anti-depressant problem and I think that
the fact he wishes hell on other humans
because he gets emotionally involved in
a conflict which within two minutes of
it's sparking off he's wishing genocide
I think that says a lot about his
personality but overall when he speaks
at length a lot of the things he says
are pretty well thought through and
pretty constructive I have nothing
against the guy let me turn to Ben
Shapiro he said let me assure you as
someone has not pimped women and bragged
about it the morality requires that
those who rope women and kidnap women
must be radic did not negotiated with so
Israel basically he says on my show I
won't be lectured on morality and
toughness by Andrew Tate his great idea
of toughness and moralities pimping
women and bragging about it on air and
then trying to quasy walk it back while
simultanously maintaining many of the
same positions and flexing his biceps
listen everyone should better tweet
whatever it is they want I'm more for an
open discourse even with people who I
think a
dead he said he that's the that's the
joke of the century man Ben Shapiro said
he's open
for open discourse he's down for open
discourse he's rejected debates with
Norman finlin Mohammad hijab with
probably danu and Abdullah andalusi as
well like he he will not literally quite
literally he will not debate anyone
except for college students not even
graduates college students now this is
the same man who before was saying that
Israel doesn't need America's help at
all they don't need America and then
recently with everything that sparked
off happened that he was like you know
America need to get involved they need
to this and that they need to send this
and that shut up frankly and and what
kind of a coward has to even mention the
nuclear option even mention it on a
population of 2.3 million people half of
whom are children and let me do the math
on that like what percentage of them are
actually militants so
2.3 million oh sorry oops 30,000
militants divided by 2.3 million wow
literally 1.3% of them 1.3% of everyone
in Gaza is a part of that uh that group
so to use a nuclear option on them which
he mentioned he brought up there's
nothing more cowardly and pusillanimous
as your um as your best friend Muhammad
hijab says Venture Piro the man that you
are so definitely scared
of issues but Andrew take is dead wrong
on a lot of these issues and the
particularly ridiculous posturing about
being a yes you're very when you want
people to make peace with terrorists who
just murdered their children very very
tough what do you say to that so Ben is
a warmonger Ben has been wrong on
basically every single issue you can
name he was with you with the vaccine
and and every other War Ben is always
calling for other people's young men to
go and die in some War he seems to love
it I don't know if he has short man
syndrome but he's always behind his desk
calling about how important it is that
big strong men like me go and die and
the reason he tweeted that and said that
is because when Hamas and Israel the
very early in the conflict I think it
was 3 days in were discussing possible
peace talks he tweeted no absolutely not
[__] them kill them all and I said I
said Ben as a man who's done his own
fighting because I've had a life of pain
and violence listen to me peace is
always worth a conversation what I said
is that we should always be prepared to
at least discuss peace he because he's a
warmonger said no peace is not worth a
conversation you're this you're that
because he's always sitting behind his
desk he must have a booster chair and
he's always running his mouth trying to
invoke violence and call for war and I
find it kind of hypocritical because a
man who's so small he would die he was
slapped on the street sitting behind a
desk and screaming for other people to
be annihilated I think is kind of it's
worse than I actually think I believe
insane I believe if he was sitting here
listening to this he would say that what
he's screaming for is for Jewish people
in Israel be able to defend themselves
and he's a jewi does is call for war and
I agree defending yourself that's all he
does that's all he does and calling for
war and call and defending yourself is
very different than genocide and Ben
like I said overall most of Ben's
worldviews and mine probably align we
don't align on the religious sect and we
don't rely on the religious points fine
but our overall worldviews of how
Society should function probably align
on many of the key issues I'm not a I
don't have a beef with Ben and I don't
watch his show and I have no idea what
he talks about a lot of the time but
what I do know is every time I turn it
on he's calling for someone else's son
to go and die in a ditch somewhere for
his interests and I don't like people
who are not advocates for peace blessed
are the peace makers said Candace who is
far more intelligent than Ben will ever
be she is completely right he replied
that rhetoric starting an argument with
me when I said we should talk about
peace I say we should talk about peace
he calls for the death of civilians and
somehow we're asking why my point of
view is seen as abstract it's insane why
can't we all just sit down and say the
fighting must end why can't we do that
why can't we sit and say nobody should
be dying let's stop using the most
advanced military weaponry on the planet
to blow the limbs off children why can't
we say that without being deemed some
kind of terrorist sympathizer or
anti-semite it's Insanity Trump came
along and didn't start a single War he's
the only one who didn't and they're
going to come along him and make him a
bad guy when a new president comes in
it's just endless war and death and
killing have you seen a dead body Pierce
have you seen people lose a [__] limb
it's disgusting I know what's happening
over there have you seen that I don't
need to tell you about the parts of my
history that I'm not prepared to share
Pierce I said it to bed I said people
who have done their own fighting and
seen their own vience and have seen
people bleed out in the street from a
stab wound are not going to be so so
smart and so quick to sit behind a desk
and call for the death of innocent
people it's disgusting what's happening
I don't want anyone to die on either
side and when I come along as a
peacemaker and say this is insane
because he's a warmonger because he has
chosen blinkers and sees one side of the
argument and refuses to accept the
humanity of Palestinians he says I'm a
bad person for calling for peace well
you know why because he'll probably
listen to his interview and say this guy
can't even describe herass as
terrorist if Ben shap and if you don't
think what happen to the people in
Israel October the 7th terroris just say
are I want all people then you are just
you are just as partisan to one side as
you believe Ben shapir did I not just
say I want all people to start dying
stop dying Pierce don't interrupt this
it's two sentences I want all people to
stop dying however I understand what is
going to happen when you create a
pressure cooker that is my that is my
answer it's extremely professional I
don't want anyone to die and because I
don't want anyone to die because I'm a
peacemaker because I'm a humanist I
understand you cannot lock people in an
open air prison for an undetermined
period of time without provoking
terrorist so out of Interest what would
you have done if you'd been Israel after
October the 7th that's what would Piers
do if he was in a concentration camp
with his his wife his parents and his
children and 2.3 million other people
really interesting question and I think
there's people who are more qualified
than me to answer given it's actually
not a very difficult question I actually
I love this topic and I want to talk
about it I love this I love this
question what would you do if you were
them I would invade I would enter on the
ground with trained rational and and and
fair soldiers who are not just out for
blood to invade in with an army of
60,000 which is double the amount of um
humus inaz or let's double that it's
quadruple say
120,000 on the ground armed men to
invade to neutralize surgically
neutralize the the the the t words all
what about the argument human
Shields the the argument of human
Shields does not apply when you're on
the ground unless they pick them up and
and shield themselves behind but that's
not happening yet that's literally what
they claimed is happening and where's
the proof for that no that yeah that's
not what's happening that they can't
even claim that because they haven't
they're not entering they enter after
they decimate the whole thing with bombs
yeah from the sky yeah I'm saying what
they do is they enter and surgically and
precisely pinpoint where the actual te's
are and off them all one by one or take
them as prisoner or whatever it might be
that's what they have to do that's what
they're responsible for that's what
they're required to do in response not
drop bombs and the fact that anyone on
the face of the Earth will sit here and
say no it's even remotely justifiable
that they drop bombs on children on and
off 15,000 innocent men women and
children while only killing 65 T's is an
absolute [__] like you have to be
insanely moronic or evil and racist to
think that it's okay to do this you know
to these these Arab people in Gaza what
they need to do is Surgical and precise
with men on the ground who are not out
for blood and by the way back in 2008
2009 during operation castled the same
uh report from Amnesty International 22
days of death and destruction they
reported that homans did not use any
human Shields but the IDF used
Palestinians as human Shields and
there's footage of it they would put
them in a street with blindfolds with a
blindfold they blindfold them put them
them in the street and then they would
put their barrel of the gun over the
guy's shoulder and they would shoot from
behind them the same thing they would
put them up in Windows they would put
them on their tanks they would put them
on their vehicles just so and actually
it's funny because they know the
Palestinians won't won't harm them they
know that the pales actually don't want
to harm innocent people yeah that's or I
get in this case to be as Fair as
possible at least not innocent
Palestinian people at the very least
is's okay using them as human Shields
and a funny example by the way Israel
recently brought Joe Biden maybe a month
ago they brought Joe Biden into the
country
to use him as a human shield because if
Iran or Lebanon or anyone attacked then
it's an attempt on a life against us
yeah yeah it's a it's an attempt on the
life of the president of the United
States they used him as a human shield
just to get a break from from L on and
from Iran it's it's so funny so again it
needs to be strategical it needs to be
precise this is their duty to enter but
instead they're like and by the way this
is why I love this topic they're such
cowards that is Israeli Army when it
comes to men holding weapons are so weak
so untrained so unprofessional and so
bad at their job because for the last
few decades they've been fighting
children with stones and men with
slingshots AR unarmed civilians and
they've practiced raiding Villages
raiding homes taking an innocent unarmed
man as prisoner including also women and
children as prisoner tying them up and
then either letting them go or throwing
them in prison for forever basically
without a trial these are the people
they fighting now all of a sudden you
have men on the ground with guns just
like them and they're not able to handle
it Palestinians for decades had to face
off to men with weapons while they had
rocks now those same men who are used to
being shot at have a
gun and the men that were shooting at
people with stones now shooting at
people with guns who do you think now
has the upper hand of that kind of
conflict the people who have been shot
out already they know what it's like not
the people who have who've had tires
thrown at them their whole life and
rocks
said we're going to try and do the same
thing again and again and again what
would you do to defend the people of
Israel good question they have the Iron
Dome which is largely literally I think
that their border security is usually
effective it's very interesting that it
wasn't on this so you would say they
would do nothing other than tighten up
security I think if I was truthfully
I'll answer the question if I was
truthfully in charge of Israel I would
have found out how our border was
penetrated I would have made sure that
was impossible to do I would have had
large conversations and discourse during
that period which would probably take
weeks to ensure that my border was
impenetrable because we were at no
genuine threat of a repeat attack and
then I would make it clear that there
will be some repercussion
unless unless there would be some
repercussion unless we can come to peace
terms I don't think the Hamas doesn't
want peace of course not but I'm saying
St position of course of course be ask
what I do I would have found out first
things first I'm a man so first things
first you fix the problem okay our bord
has been penetrated how do we make sure
that doesn't happen again how did it
happen internal investigation make sure
the border secure now our civilians are
safe our civilians are safe which buys
us time let's have a conversation and
see if we can actually reason with a Mas
if we can't then there might be there
might be some military intervention but
there certainly wouldn't be bombing
hospitals Cruise missling refugee camps
there wouldn't be any of the things was
going on now absolutely not you wouldn't
trying to take the people no because
this is a rushed and emotional response
and that's why I would have prevented I
would have made sure as a man I didn't
make a rushed and emotional response
You' be you'd be more like Neville
Chamberlain trying to do peace with the
Nazis in Winston church or trying to
kill them well what a stupid comparison
like what an absolutely moronic
comparison like
firstly a group of 30,000 concentration
camp detainees turned violent is not the
same as Germany during World War II I
don't want to say the trigger word you
know they're they're they're not the
same by any way shape or
form secondly he said that it's been
stated they don't want peace but what
does that mean like where do you get
that from from they just agreed to a
ceasefire and they've agreed to
ceasefires in the past and you know why
they don't want peace because peace
doesn't look like both parties are happy
and no one's fighting each other peace
looks like Israel's chilling and 2.3
million people are still in a
concentration camp in Gaza that's what
peace looks like that was your pece for
the last few years when there wasn't any
war or any fighting you say that like
Hamas is firing Rockets from the Gaza
shrip they're fing Rockets from a
concentration camp they're basically
banging at the door begging for them and
2.3 million people to get out and this
is the biggest Act of Terror that's been
done in recent history because it's been
done against 2.3 million people where
they're all shoved into an open air
prison a concentration camp and they're
given a condition that you can leave
once hom either surrenders or you give
them up somehow and you neutralize them
yourself the innocent civilians so this
is illegal in violation of international
law for multiple reasons not just the
fact that they're uh they put them in
there or the fact that they're keeping
them in there on one condition that they
give up their own government but it's an
act of it's purely an act of Terror
because they're saying you're going to
sit here and suffer in these inhumane
living conditions we're going to
routinely mow the lawn bomb you while
referring to you as animals or in the
most dignified way Human animals unless
you neutralize your own political party
and your own government that's exactly
what the terror people do I'm trying not
to say the word to get demonetized but
that's exactly what Terror people do
they can't attack an entire army they
can't they can't neutralize the Army
itself the government itself so they
attack civilians and hope to scare the
people into revolting or into giving
them up or into not supporting them
anymore so that they can have the
power it's textbook but just because the
white people don't say it the white
people don't say it's an act of Terror
all of a sudden it's not an act of
Terror it's very very very pathetic once
again that's an interesting question
you're an appeaser not a warrior well I
still think I'm a warrior but I think
that when you're a warrior you have to
be very capable and that's what Neville
Chamberlain's view was we we should do
peace with the N you have to be very
understanding of your power and you have
to use it responsibil responsibly and
just like I said earlier when I'm trying
to be responsible about what I say to
the young men of the world I would
understand as Israel I must be
responsible with my massive military
might to make sure I don't kill
civilians and I would sit and try and
make a measured response and I'd be a
professional and I would consider them
human beings and I would secure my
border and try and come up with a plan
better than oh no I'm mad I'm emotional
now let's go kill everyone I think
that's the wrong response correct I
don't think I don't think that's the
right thing to do
we've spent a long time talking um
you're going to find out at some stage
today or in the next few days whether
you're going to get your possessions
back that rather happen or not happen
but then there's likely to be a trial
and that will determine how you spend
the next 10 years of your life or most
certainly which is a sobering thought
for anyone yeah when you look back on
the whole Arc of the last few years you
know you've expressed some regret
because of your turning to Islam your
changing in your philosophy from a
religious perspective you've
acknowledged that some of the stuff you
used to do was
immoral do you look at the journey
you've gone on here and think that in a
way not withstanding the Matrix and
everything else that maybe you yourself
could have done things differently to
avoid being in this position ABS
absolutely I'm a man and I take absolute
self-accountability you have to as a man
your superpower is looking in the mirror
and understanding everything that
happens to you both good and bad to a
degree is your fault it could have all
been influenced I could have avoided all
of this I could have avoided The Matrix
attacks or sorry I could have avoided
jail cell if you don't let me using that
term I could have avoided all the
negative press I could have chosen to
work in Starbucks and just stay to
nobody I made choices that put me in
this position I take responsibility for
them I said things on the internet in a
satirical way on videos that got 110
views when YouTube was brand new that I
did not expect to become the most viral
videos in the world because I didn't
expect to become the most famous and
known person on the planet that's all
true I'm not saying I have no part to
play in any of this however I can still
say that I'm completely innocent I can
still say that is only my fame and
notoriety that has inspired the
prosecution service to try and even put
me in jail in the first place I can
still say that there's some unfair
policing in the world depending on your
political views I can still say all of
those things while accepting absolute
responsibility for the situation I am in
Andrew Tate thank you very much thank
you sir
bro this is this is the Asin
enties yeah a lot to be said a lot was
said a lot wasn't said by peers
unfortunately but at the end of the day
I mean like the truth speaks for itself
like all you guys have to do is just
look at the name of the country and then
Amnesty International or United Nations
or um uh bet salum it's a big one as
well and you will see all the reports
impartial unbiased completely fair and
they do their own investigations and you
will see the truth of the matter I'm not
no one's going to say that any specific
organization is perfect or everyone
within that organization's perfect or
people haven't killed innocent uh people
or taken hostages any of that stuff we
will say that and we will condemn any
Act of violation of international law
and even more so any Act of violation of
Islamic law we will
condemn but we condemn it impartially on
both sides what you have here is a group
of people peers is amongst them who
refuses to condemn one side for the same
thing that he condemns the other side
for and that is hypocritical it's
disingenuous and it's it's it's very
unjal istic as well very very unjal and
the reason I say that is because as a
journalist he's giving his own opinions
based on the facts and the facts hold up
on both cases and both ends but he will
hold one opinion for one and a different
opinion for the other when they have
Israel's done literally the same thing
but 10 times worse in the last few
decades may Allah guide his heart to
overcome these dou standards and may
Allah bless our new Reaver brother Andre
Tate for defending not just the Muslims
because at the end of the day if
somebody else was oppressed I would say
me Allah bless him too for defending
those that are oppressed because that's
our job as Muslim that's our duty as
Muslims but may Allah bless him for
genuinely just defending the oppressed
and speaking the truth and being
Unapologetic despite being in the
position that he's in I know he he
probably gets a lot of deals and and
offers to not speak the truth but the
fact that he's still doing it may Allah
bless him and reward him and keep him
sincere there's um before we end there's
just one comment I don't know how an
occupation got the right to defend
itself it just makes no sense um the
right to self-defense is actually a very
specific term in international law in
the UN Charter I think it's article 51
specific L it says that um the right to
self-defense essentially is is the right
to wage war that's what it means and
that when you wage war it has to be
against another Sovereign Nation which
Gaza is not Sovereign Nation um but it
has to be against another Sovereign
Nation and it has to be reported to the
security Council under specific
pretenses that were there and you have
to outline your case for what you're
doing I'm sure Ukraine did that when it
was invaded um beforehand Israel did not
do that I don't think they cited article
51 and if they did it doesn't make sense
and it doesn't uh add up according to
special repertoire Franchesca albanesi
who says that this can only be invoked
against another Sovereign Nation not a
group of occupied people who are
protected persons even if they are
militants uh enforcing some kind of
armed resistance against the occupation
so not only do they not have the right
to claim self-defense under
international law that that claim of
self-defense and that right of
resistance actually goes to the pales
people as a whole including any militant
group that arises from them now again
that doesn't exempt that group from
committing atrocities or violating the
law they should be held accountable just
like anybody else but the right to
self-defense specifically unequivocally
goes to the Palestinian people who are
occupied not to
Israel do you have any more uh super
chats or messages that you want to
address uh I don't think there are any
super chats I I might have missed them I
apologize if I do but um I think I'm
good inshallah if you guys have any uh
comments comment now or forever hold
your peace or at least until the next
stream which I don't know when that's
going to be but in we'll do this more
consistently
inah guys link to donating to the
Palestine fundraiser even
though it is on the ground it's getting
in yes C far no CES far this is we can't
forget about this this is not a trendy
thing that the fake woke just care about
because it's trending like BLM and then
once it's done everyone goes back to
their lives so link is in the
description inshallah and we are
launching merch soon so make sure to
sign up for the email list if you want a
discount code when we launch first 500
participants only
inshallah bless you guys M we're going
to go ahead and end this stream off with
that being said like comment subscribe
share the stream with those who you
think should hear it may Allah forgive
us for our our sins our our mistakes may
Allah allow us to be the best example
for the Muslims may Allah allow us to
enter into the highest levels of Jenna
and um may Allah allow me to be on the
PE Morgan show so I can uh politely and
intellectually destroy him or change his
heart may Allah guide him and may Allah
allow us to just guys pray for us and
our protection inshallah make Dua for us
and make Dua for the brothers and
sisters that are oppressed may Allah
free us and restore Justice in this life
so we don't have to wait till the next
inshah and with that being
said we'll see you guys on the next
one